Eric is selling raffle tickets for a
school fundraiser each ticket costs
three dollars and he knows the amount of
money he collects is a function of how
many tickets he sells what are the
domain and range for that function so
let's write the the function for how
much money he collects so I'll call that
M M the function will be M and it's a
function of how many tickets he sells so
it's a function of T for tickets so M
the amount of money collects as a
function of the number of tickets he
sells it's a pretty straightforward
function every ticket cost three dollars
he gets three dollars for every ticket
so it's going to be 3 times T dollars or
3t dollars that's how much money he
collects now they ask us what are the
domain and range for that function and
it sounds all fancy and difficult but
just remember the domain the domain this
just means what what can i input into
the function can i input input into into
the function so another way to think
about it is what are the possible T's
that can be input into this function the
range is what are the possible values
that the function can take on so think
about it he might at first say oh I
could put any T there but think about
the actual reality of what he's doing he
is selling tickets and so we can't sell
negative tickets he might sell zero
tickets and he might sell a gazillion
tickets I guess he could sell on an
infinite amount of tickets at some point
that becomes unrealistic but he
definitely can't sell negative tickets
he also is not going to sell half of a
ticket every ticket he sells is it is a
whole number it's an integer so the
domain the domain for this function the
domain the domain we could say T T has
to be has to be a non-negative a
non-negative non-negative integer I
think that covers what I just talked
about non-negative instead of
Paschal could be zero he might literally
sell no tickets he can't sell a negative
one ticket or negative two so he it's
anything that's non negative it has to
be an integer he can't sell half of a
ticket so that and indefinitely
well it has to be an integer so that's
our domain and let's think about what
our range is our range is the possible
values that we can take on if T is
always going to be a non-negative
integer then what's 3t always going to
be well it's going to be a non-negative
multiple of three so non non negative
multiples multiples of three think about
it you can he'll never be able to
collect two dollars because he could
either sell zero tickets and collect get
nothing let me write this down he might
sell zero tickets so M of zero he's
gonna get zero dollars M of if he sells
one ticket he's gonna get three dollars
if he sells two tickets he's gonna get
six dollars so he's never gonna be able
to get two or for every every possible
value for the amount of money he
collects for our function has to be a
multiple of three it's going to be a
non-negative multiple three because the
domain is non-negative integers